and europe is also baking in the heat
this morning record-setting triple-digit
temperatures in portugal and spain are
making it hard for firefighters battling
a series of wildfires there and italy is
in the middle of a severe drought that
threatens some of that country's most
famous food exports chris livesay
reports now from an italian region that
is running out of water
we shouldn't be able to walk here this
is foundations of bridge and there was
also a river report here ancient roman
ruins in rome's tiber river dating back
nearly 2 000 years now revealed by a
heat wave and italy's worst drought in
seven decades says professor of urban
planning tom rankin the water normally
is up to our waist or shoulder height at
this point and now i'd say it's gone
beyond the wake-up call
some towns are now rationing water and
rome could be next now there's a trick
to getting a good drink out of these
roman fountains
but that's only if you get here in time
the city is considering shutting them
all off the drought worsens
experts blame global warming this month
in the italian alps 11 climbers were
crushed to death when record
temperatures caused part of this glacier
to collapse
downhill in much of italy's north the
heat and drought have left rice fields
for risotto bone dry and the po river
valley which produces 40 percent of
italy's food like pasta and wine now in
a government state of emergency in the
rome countryside the alarm is audible
i can hear the grass crunching beneath
our feet the petrucci olive orchard has
crafted exquisite extra virgin oil since
the 1600s
but the drought has turned its future
into a row of tombstones half are dead
and this is one of them yes sabina
petrucci now has to truck in water what
does this mean for people who want to
buy good olive oil we will ask a lot
more for the final product price so
higher energy costs and the drought mean
higher prices at the grocery store yes
we have to think about all this business
even if it's a family business since
forever so
after centuries of making olive oil
this might be the end yes for cbs
mornings chris lives say rome